[Applause]
[Music]
the surprise package at the medal battle
of 2017 in Ferrum the average age of the
van members is just 19 the Dutch group
only got together nine months before the
competition Buchan was their biggest gig
yet so practice was key we practiced
three times a week and we're just
drilling the songs you know just this
over and over every part we play it a
hundred times
I have everything needed needed to be
perfect and it was it was really really
fun to do we saw we saw self grow as a
band and it was really really cool to
see hardwork is a must but to win
against 27 international acts in Bakken
you also need luck and it seems the
weather gods were smiling down on in
thier own
we looked at the Weather Channel this
morning and Lars was saying yeah it's
raining when we're playing so everyone
is inside tent and cope of Josh from
Switzerland and from the US I thought
came to us and he said yeah it was
raining so hard and everyone just
stormed inside of the tent so I think
we're lucky that it that's raining
[Music]
until now in Ferrum have never performed
in front of more than a hundred people
here they have to Wow an overcrowded
tent but it's not a problem the
musicians from the Dutch city of I know
fanat stun because they've studied their
craft it all started at the College of
metal Factory where you can study metal
and iron stove and yeah that's where it
all started of the fuel line of changes
it's called a metal Factory because a
lot of teachers there are very big in
the metal world like really from with
implantation like that but we are taught
the business side of music so we have an
advantage and that's how to take care of
that so studies at the Music Academy
were worth it at the metal battlin
buckin the band came in third place
[Applause]
in Ferrum the metal newcomers might
still be young but they're already like
seasoned pros so watch this space
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
you
[Applause]